in 2002 ebay bought
paypal for 1.5 billion dollars
an acquisition that made paypal's
20-something co-founders
very very wealthy young men these
included people
like peter thiel max levchin and elon
musk
that group and other early investors in
paypal
would go on to become known as the
paypal mafia
using their proceeds from the sale to
fund a range of startups and businesses
that have become very successful
in household names out of this group
elon musk has been by far the most
successful with his creation of
spacex and electric vehicle company
tesla
so much so that tesla has now created a
mafia of its own
a group of new companies that are
emerging in the electric vehicle
battery and autonomous vehicle space
who could be dubbed the tesla mafia
tesla had built a reputation that it
didn't constrain
its actions by what had been done before
and this was
tremendously exciting enticing and
empowering to an engineer to join a
company
that is both highly mission driven but
also
espouses the notion that there will be
fundamental engineering happening that
need not be
kind of constrained by past ways of
doing things tesla reached out to me it
wasn't a job that you apply for
tesla was attempting to do this project
called model s and
it was led by a gentleman called elon
musk and elon was looking for a new
chief engineer
i visited the prototype shop
at tesla where the very first concept of
model s
was being constructed
and it was really a mercedes platform
with the roof cut off
and the fiberglass top representing what
model s would look like broadly
glued on it's death trap on wheels
and i took one look at it and i thought
oh goodness me this is what this is
where they're at and
i was intrigued clearly elon had the
the provenance and clearly he
had the ambition and you know
sometimes you think this is a great
opportunity in life
this is my chance that i've been waiting
for for all these years to show what i
can
really do we see five particularly
interesting
individuals who look to be members of
this new tesla mafia
they include sterling anderson who
oversaw development of
tesla's autopilot semi-autonomous drive
system
when he was at the company after he left
he went on to co-found
aurora innovation which has become a
leading developer of self-driving
vehicle tech tesla is very good at
aligning people around a mission about
setting outrageous goals
about establishing a workplace and
environment
where expectations are extraordinarily
high but also constraints
are extraordinarily low which is to say
solve the problem
by whatever means you can come up with
despite the fact that it may never have
been done before
these were kind of foundational
principles that allowed a
fertile environment for top flight
engineers to do great work
and something that myself and other
peers who have since left to do their
own thing
continue to espouse many similar things
in many ways tesla is very similar to
aurora on some of these dimensions right
strong kind of mission-driven
organization highly talented people
an organization willing to set
outrageous goals and aggressively pursue
them
and you know setting a high bar for
employees not only in terms of kind of
their skill but also
in terms of kind of the way they work
additionally there's also gene
bertichevsky who was the chief engineer
for the battery system
for the roadster the very first tesla
vehicle that launched in 2008. we
believed in the mission
as it stands today we would get
critiqued as oh it's just
sports cars for rich people but that was
from day one that wasn't the plan the
goal was always this mass-market car
you know not even the model 3 but sort
of that next car that's coming that's
going to be even lower cost
and and the plan was there from day one
so we knew the importance that the
roadster played
to what we've seen unfold over the last
15 years
and what's going to unfold over the next
20 and there are absolutely moments
where we didn't think we were gonna make
it
on regular occasions but i think you
built a lot of camaraderie and it was
incredibly thrilling
i would drive the only prototype in
existence home on the weekends
for you know testing and it was also
really fun to share that and kind of
show your friends what the future was
going to look like jean has co-founded
and leads seala nanotechnologies which
is developing advanced materials to make
lithium-ion batteries
cheaper and more energy dense we're
competing to make the best battery in
the world
we're going to be commercially launching
in consumer devices this year
so our technology is ready today it's
not waiting another five years to see if
it's ready
but at the end of the day we're also all
competing against
combustion cars and and ending the the
age of ice vehicles
so i think we're more allies than we are
competitors but the technology paths
we're pursuing are a bit different
there's also peter rollinson who was
chief engineer
for the tesla model s peter these days
is ceo and cto of lucid motors
which is about to launch the lucid air
arguably the most advanced electric car
ever brought out and that may even be
more compelling in many ways than
tesla's best products
i hope it's a product that people will
really fall in love with
because it is in itself a true labor of
love it's taken many years from a
brilliant and dedicated team
to create this because just like model s
no one person designs a car it's too
complex
a team designed model s and a team
has designed lucid air a passionate team
who are all working to make something
really next level
and it has to be we're up against
mercedes-benz dammit
how can we compete there's only one way
product
is king product defines brand
tesla's been very effective at creating
a whole range of of entrepreneurs
because the company required
a lot of ingenuity and creativity to
solve difficult
problems to get products out the door as
quickly as possible
and that ingenuity turns out to be a
common thread
among members of the tesla mafia
all the companies look to be very well
positioned
to be significant players and
potentially
even tesla competitors in the evolving
world
of electric vehicles advanced batteries
and autonomous vehicles
[Music]